all right man listen right now people
you you viral right now when is this
song coming out
they mixing that [ __ ] down right now so
i got my producer you know i'm saying uh
swiss cheese yeah so let's talk about
this man uh you know what
i what i what i it's entertaining to me
that at times
you will speak on [ __ ] that don't got
nothing to do with you but it stirs up a
lot of [ __ ]
you know what i i i really wasn't gonna
say nothing at first right
talking about the meek mill situation
yeah but see what i don't like i'm gonna
call it spade a spade right
whether it's in favor of me or or not
right and it's like
what i've been noticing about this
industry is that
people tend because of who you are
they sweep [ __ ] under the rug but if the
same for somebody else committed
the same act they're crucified and i
believe you know
hey everybody got to be held accountable
for what they do
you know what i mean like for instance
um you know i got mixed feelings about
this little kid
you know what i mean because yeah he did
what he did but on this
one six nine yeah on the same note he
shouldn't have never been in position to
do what he did
you know i mean you know this thing we
got in the streets right it ain't for
everybody
and it's just not a free fall it ain't
like [ __ ] uh magic mountain
you show up buy a ticket and get in
there's certain things you got to go
through certain things you got that has
to be proven
before somebody is is allowed to come in
you know and the fact that they allow
him to come in is with
you know him being inside of it is what
gave him
information you know they chose to bring
him into it
once you brought him in and you allowed
him to see certain things you're
discussing certain things
you know what i mean um he shouldn't
have never
had the information that he had when he
got put up under that light
you know what i mean everything ain't
for everybody and and i really think he
was
he was in uh he was in character the
whole time he was using the block boy
street cred
you know everything about the kid
besides what he said he was
no just you know the you know the um the
gay community
has adopted the rainbow as um
as pretty they're flagged right the kid
got rainbow head
i mean we do the bath on everything
about the kid it totally defines
you know what they allowed him to do you
know what i mean so
um i already know what they did they do
what they always do they press play on
the kid
they let the kid hear things that was
going on and you know behind his back
and because
he don't fall up under that script he
don't fall up
under that real code no matter i can hit
somebody can press play
and show me a dude running a train on my
wife and and
this to do to kill my brother and this
this this
the code say whatever it is is going on
i got to deal with that how i got to
deal with that i don't deal with that
through the law
i got to keep my mouth shut when i get
it you got to handle it
yeah the way you handle it exactly but
again that's me
and and i think that they put this kid
in the situation
that he shouldn't have been in and what
he did was
he just went back to who he really was
he took the costume off
so it's i got mixed emotions of what we
call this kid to snitch
because i i believe uh civilians don't
snitch they tell the truth
so we're looking i mean they don't
snitch they tell the truth
they put this dude in this situation
that he shouldn't have been in
right so he did what he did and i
believe even right now today
uh he uses what he does
as a marketing tool because he has no
obligation
to the politics of the streets
he has none he don't care how it goes
he's just you know a little kid
playing and doodling and it's and he
it's allowed they're allowing it to
happen you know what i mean you know i
think he got a death wish i think he
want to go all the water one day